If there is one thing you need to know
as a trader, is liquidity. I scalp and
day traded the NASDAQ over the last
years. I've participated in the CME
Group Equity Cup and in the World
Trading Cup, ranking in the top podium
every single time. And what you will
learn here in this video is the
foundation of my trading. Financial
markets, stock, crypto, everything,
every financial asset class that comes
to your mind, it's moved by a flow of
orders matching liquidity. So, it's
crucial that you understand how these
forces are related to understand why and
how the market moves. And this video
will most likely be the last one you
will ever need about liquidity heat map.
Before you ask, no, it's not going to be
a video where I explain you how to draw
lines above the top, below the bottom,
trend lines, too. Search for liquidity
that market makers will come to hunt
your stop loss. I will show you the real
deal. I will show you how professionals
watch the heat map and understand where
the path of least resistance is. Even if
the sellers will try to push it through,
the fact that there is passive liquidity
here is the break and protect. So,
trying to get and as you can see, this
is an example live of how the reload
unfold, okay? Look at this beauty. And
how they should position themselves. I
will show you how the plumbing of the
market works and why with this kind of
information you're accessing [music]
somewhere that 95% of retail traders
completely ignore. And by the way, on
the 8th of May, we are going to host
webinar [music] where we talk about the
liquidity heat map and we are going to
go over the best [music] and the
cleanest heat map setup. You don't want
to miss it. Let's start with the concept
of retail liquidity from a beginner
point of view. So, retail is usually
seen as resting above the high and below
the low in a compression phase or above
the top swing and below the top swing in
a directional market phase. This is not
wrong, but it's only accurate 60 to 70%
of the time because you need to guess
where liquidity is. You don't know where
liquidity is. Maybe in this case where
you would expect that liquidity is here,
when you are going up there is a big
liquidity level here that you are
ignoring because you are trying to
assume and predict where the liquidity
will be because you miss the software
and the technology to understand the
actual liquidity. The actual liquidity
heat map it's a technology step from the
usual order book because it shows you
also the historical movement of the
liquidity and it's really visually
appealing and easy to understand because
you have the darker level or the level
it's more powerful from a visual
perspective and it's more lighting if
the level it's important. So, for
example, here let's say that you have
100 contracts, this level will be
visually stronger than all the other
level where the liquidity it's really
low. So, from a scalper point of view,
this kind of visualization of the orders
is really convenient and you have always
an interaction of two forces. You have
the aggressive market orders, bubbles,
and the passive liquidity. These two
match together. So, the aggressive
liquidity is matched with the passive
liquidity and this is how the market
moves and the exchange happen. Let's go
on the market micromechanics. Market
takers, they eat. These are the bubbles
that eat liquidity level. Market makers,
they offer. So, you have the best bid,
best ask. You have the level in the
middle, the 100, and you have 33
contracts resting passive liquidity on
the 101, and 48 contracts passive
liquidity resting on the 99. The
difference between these two is called
the spread. Now, let's go on. If you are
in this case, 25 aggressive market order
arrive to meet the passive liquidity
order at 101. So, 25 aggressive order
match with 33 passive orders on the
single level, 101. Now, my question for
you is, are these 33 enough to meet the
demand of the 25? Yes, they are. In this
case, on the 101, you have enough supply
to meet the aggressive market forces of
the buyers. Perfect. What you have here?
You have eight contract remaining on the
101, and the filling completely on this
level of the aggressive market
participants. Now, let's say that you
have 25 aggressive sellers. They meet
the offer at the 40 at the 99 level. 41
passive orders, it's enough to fulfill
the demand? Yes. So, you have eight
contract passive liquidity remaining on
101, and 16 contract remaining on the 99
level. Now, let's say that the market
participants gets more interest in
getting into position, and you get 75
contracts. They need to meet the 101
level. How much offer there is on this
level from the passive liquidity side?
Eight. On the level above, 42. Is this
enough? No. They need to go even higher
to the 103 level. So, what happens? They
eat the first level. You have still 67
contract missing. Then, what you have?
You step up to 102. Is this enough? No,
not yet enough. You still need to go to
the next level to meet the full demand.
So, you have now 31 contracts remaining
from a passive liquidity perspective on
the 103, and you met the complete
necessity from aggressive market orders
to be filled, and you did this movement.
This is how the market really moves. So,
the main takeaways you can get from here
is that you buy and sell at the price
you want, but you don't have a guarantee
that you'll get filled. This is the
perspective of the passive order. So,
you have price certainty, but not time
certainty and not execution certainty.
You don't know if they will fill you at
the level that you want. The aggressive
market participants are the one that
say, "Fill me now. I want to be filled
now." So, you buy and sell when you
want. You'll pay a worse price. You pay
for the spread because you have the
necessity to be filled in your order
now. Let's go now to the books low, the
path of least resistance. So, let's say
that we fix the effort, and we say that
the effort is 50. So, you have 50
contracts here. It doesn't matter if
it's aggressive on the top going by or
aggressive on the bottom side. What I
want to explain you here is the passive
forces. In this case, the path of least
resistance is down. Why the path of
least resistance in down? Because to go
above, you need to fulfill 273
passive orders. The total limit above
the price is 273.
Below the price is 122.
So, you have a five price level. The
total of this price level above is 273.
The total of the five price level below
is 122. So, fixing the effort, it's
easier to move price down in this
particular behavior. And this is why you
have this slope like this because the
path of least resistance is on the
downside and this is really important to
understand when you need for example to
take a trading decision on the short
term. Now, the liquidity heat map, how
is it structured? How is it based? As I
was explaining to you, you have the
brightest color on the darkest color
when the level is important. You can set
it for for this case here we have the 78
that is a super important passive
liquidity level where the price could
bounce if it reach have a really bright
color and then you have this 33 and 40
level that stand out of the other ones
because they are more important. They
are more loaded with contract and the
power of the liquidity heat map is that
you have an historical DOM. So you can
see how the liquidity move. You can see
here that the liquidity raised and
raised again going on. So it means that
they are lifting, okay, the path of
least resistance. And in this case you
see that the price is bouncing between
this level of the heat map, the 101 and
the 98 doing this work here and you have
a strong limit above that could stop the
advance of price going on. And now I
want to continue with the common book
pattern. Let's go over multiple book
pattern. We have the bid reload. So when
you are in a consolidation phase,
compression phase and you see in this
point in time appearing 110 contract
supporting your movement and your idea.
This one is a bid reload and this one is
giving information that there is someone
really big that want to be filled on the
long. And what is the immediate reaction
of the algorithm of the market? They
will try to front run it. So there is a
big probability that you will go
directly to this level. Be careful also
because this pattern here it's used a
lot by the spoofing, okay, there is a
market manipulation technique where they
put this order here but they don't
really intend to be filled to manipulate
the movement of the market above to
short from a better level, okay? Now,
spoofing is an illegal trading
technique, but still nowadays you can
see them in the market that is still
used every day, okay? And the bid reload
here is an information, for example,
let's say that you have a bias long and
you want to go long till this level.
Seeing this kind of information is an
amazing information to validate your
idea. The iceberg it's can be called
invisible liquidity. Why invisible
liquidity? Because you cannot see heat
from the heat map because it's a reload.
There are only eight contract here, but
every time sellers step in and consume
it, they get reloaded. Reloaded for
hundreds of time. So, even if you see
eight here, maybe it can be 500
contracts, 400. You need specific
indicator for it, an iceberg indicator
that show you when there is a
algorithmic activity of reloading a
price level. Then here you have one of
my favorite one, the book sweeping is
the
that you have seen probably in hundreds
of interview and live trading for that
I've made is when you have a book
sweeping, a fast movement. Specifically,
this one you can find really close to
all-time high, all-time low of the
range. Or if you are really close to the
high of the New York session or on the
session, the market approach this level
and you have a book sweeping usually in
this kind of level. So, if you are
positioned, you can take an asymmetrical
risk to reward. You can risk few ticks
to get a really good risk to reward
multiplier. And the last one is the book
flip. This is really convenient also for
scalpers because let's say that here you
are on the short side, you took a short.
You see the break through of this level
of liquidity, so you have a continuation
at least till here. And you see also
that they reload the level of liquidity.
So, they are like going down, closing
the door to go above and going down.
This is important because if you are
covered here, you can trail your stop
loss here or you can also add other
contract because they are confirming you
that they want to go down. Okay, let's
go now to the heat map liquidity pattern
and let's start with the one that we saw
before, the buyers reload. This is a
situation where you may be have a long
bias for your asset, you have a setup
and you want to get a better feeling,
you wants to get a probability area of a
potential reversal play like you can see
here on the bottom and of a reload. So
you have both the setups where you can
go mean reverting in direction of of the
main trend and when you can reload. In
this one, this is amazing because you
have a protection wall that is there.
This is a resting liquidity, is not
fresh liquidity and as you can see the
market approach here and get absorbed
the first time, strike again this area,
absorb the second time, strike this
area, absorb the third time and then you
have already potential liquidity levels
to reach from the price. The price
extend here. This is the mean reverting
on the protection wall of the buyers in
line with the main direction. So you
need to start with an idea. But for
scalpers, where you want before to see
the market getting aggressive on your
direction. So you want to see maybe big
trades confirming that there is an
aggression there and that there is
intention to go higher, then in this
case you can use this one. This one is
called the reload and is where you are
really close to a resting liquidity
level and you see the buyers reloading
passive liquidity and getting
aggressive. This is a really high
probability break break and retest play,
okay? This one it's really easy to trade
because if you have a directional bias,
a probability directional bias, you can
enter at the breakout protected below
the reload level and you can run the
setups with the first take profit on the
major liquidity areas and the second and
third take profit on other resting
liquidity area. Remember that to take
this kind of setup, you need to start
with a directional bias and a
probability framework that comes from
the order flow. Now, let's go on the
second example. This one is the seller's
reload. Truly easy to identify. We have
a market that is closed inside a resting
liquidity fresh area of the buyers and
is protected on the aggression from the
seller. So, who is pushing the market?
The sellers are getting aggressive here.
They are trying to break through this
level and this is the ultimate
confirmation you need because you can
see that they get aggressive and at the
same time they reload fresh liquidity.
This is an information that they want to
fuel the movement to the next liquidity
levels. This is exactly where the price
reached. Then they come back to the
level, they reload again as you can see
and they get aggressive again protected
with aggressive orders back to the
liquidity level. And you can see that
they both put aggression and resting
liquidity protection area. This is a
good confirmation. Then, in this kind of
setup, you always needs to be careful
because the price usually goes to the
next liquidity cluster. And the next
liquidity cluster in this case was
really close, okay? So, the risk to
reward is not the best, but the
confirmation that you get here gets
respected for four additional times.
One, two, three and the fourth time here
when the price explodes short. Now,
let's see other setup and let's go on
other example here on the heat map. This
one here, it's an amazing example of the
framing of the liquidity area. So, let's
say that you are in a directional bias
long for the day. Maybe you have an IVB,
maybe you have statistical projection of
the the pivot for the reversal or maybe
you use the volume profile or the view
up and you are below the extension. You
have anything that gives you the
probability that from this area you are
going to rebound. Now, if you don't have
the heat map, you could be a little bit
confused on where to cover yourself. So,
you can say, "Look, I enter here and I
cover below the low." But, here you can
see that there was a main resting
liquidity level, and there is also an
additional liquidity wall here. So, the
best play from a probability side here
is to see the reload that they put
reload plus absorption. It's an amazing
pattern to join with an amazing feeling
here. But, to be careful, also, you
could decide to enter here, yes, but to
put your stop loss below the next
liquidity area. So, you have still an
amazing risk to reward to the next
liquidity area, but you are being
careful of the market not taking you out
during an accumulation phase, because it
could make, for example, here another
spike, then bouncing back, and then
going to the next liquidity area. This
is also a pattern that I need to give
credit to Eric Stokke, because this is
the grill, the barbecue, when you have
multiple liquidity area, and the price
gets aggressive here to eat all these
level of liquidity. And you can see here
from the aggressive market order that is
pushing really hard to slice through
them, because this is I mean a perfect
example of a sustained move, where you
have aggression, aggression, aggression,
and the price is eating all the passive
liquidity level really aggressively. And
these are all partial profit that you
can take, because the market usually
reach a point of exhaustion here when
there are there is a cluster of
liquidity level, and then reverts. Let's
go on the next one. And this one is an
example of an aggressive breakout on a
resting liquidity level protected by the
reload. This is important, because when
you see here the bubble, you could think
about a potential absorption. But, when
you have a clue and you see that at the
same time, okay, they load resting
liquidity fresh, and they get aggressive
on the level, is because they want to do
a sustained move. So, this one is an
additional probability booster for a
break and retest pattern to go above.
And this one is one of my favorite
pattern of the book, because when you
see something like this, and you have
maybe, I don't know, a footprint
aggression, a big trade from the
execution of order, you cannot see if
this liquidity is sustained in the book.
But with this pattern, you can decide to
take the trades that have the highest
probability of following up on the
trend, and you can also decide, let me
see if the result of the price is
positive, I can enter on the test,
protect myself below the wall reload,
and go to the next liquidity level,
maybe for a 1:2 1:3 risk to reward.
Let's go on the next one, and this is a
textbook example of a liquidity cluster
wall. You have a resting liquidity here
on the 27,625
and on the 27,630,
and you can see here that the price
tried to break through, but you see the
first line absorption, and the second
time they tried to come again here, they
cannot surpass the first aggression.
This is a strong confirmation that this
is a filled auction, and the price will
reverse for the path of least
resistance. Where is the path of least
resistance? You can see a liquidity wall
here. This could be the next level where
they go to reload to finally take the
strength they need to reach the second
liquidity level. And also you can see
that when they break out this, they fuel
the movement with aggressive order, and
this is your confirmation that we are
going to flip the auction on the short
term. Remember that this is market micro
mechanics, so you always need a
confirmation from the higher time frame
on what's happening here. Let's go on
the next one. This one is the Stucky
Grill, and this is when you have the
book that have multiple levels of
liquidity above, and you can see that
the market is usually during the
opening, start to get a really
aggressive during the opening, okay? And
you can see that they protect their
movement, so they do the first push, put
fresh liquidity to protect and fuel the
movement. Here, they do the second push,
and they put fresh liquidity to fuel.
This means they wants to go up, they
want to capitalize up. As you can see,
they are not putting liquidity, this is
empty. They are not putting protective
liquidity to protect this level, but
they are going to put protective fresh
liquidity to fuel the aggression on the
way up. And this is all example of
reload of fresh liquidity till they
reach the final take profit in this
area. This is another amazing pattern
that you can use to boost your
probability. Then we go here and we can
see an example of a cluster of liquidity
wall. And this is important because this
can be the most tricky one because you
have an absorption on the top, you have
a liquidity wall on the top and you will
think to go short here. But when you see
that there is a strong cluster of four
levels stacked on each other way higher
than this aggressive liquidity of the
sellers, all these levels here on the
Nasdaq, you can understand that the
highest probability here is that they
will get a full fill, okay? You can see
the absorption on this level to go to
the next liquidity level on the way up.
Remember the market is a path of least
resistance, okay? And all the players,
specifically institutional player, use
execution alpha mechanism. And that's
the reason it's really important if you
want to improve also a little bit your
risk to reward or your risk management
or use the micro mechanics to get a
higher probability of getting your
trade, this is the best way to do it and
to improve the feeling of your order.
Now, let's go to the flip of the
auction. The flip of the auction it's an
amazing example of the battle. As you
can see, buyers getting aggressive,
buyers getting aggressive, sellers
getting aggressive here, but they are
protected by this liquidity wall that
you can see here, okay? When the sellers
take the final decision to breach
through, this is important because at
the same time you see the protection of
the aggressive market orders sustained
by the liquidity wall. So, what does it
mean? That if the price try to go back
here, it will find the resistance on the
liquidity level. Sometimes it can spike
up, fill all and collapse. And this is a
break and protect pattern. When you have
a breakout sustained breakout, it's
sustained by a fresh liquidity and this
is a really high probability of going to
the next liquidity. Maybe this is a
small movement for you, but it's enough
to put your position to break even. Why?
Because if they start accumulating here
and they come back, there is a high
probability that they will reverse the
market. Now, let's go on the iceberg.
What is the iceberg? We like to call the
iceberg the hidden liquidity because
it's a reload on levels that are
invisible, that you cannot see because
they don't put the amount in the order
book, but they reload the level with
algorithm. So, you can see that they did
a reload here, and uh you had this arrow
here that is showing you where the
sellers found a wall, a wall from the
iceberg, and even if the liquidity, the
resting liquidity was not so high, this
one was a super important level. And you
can see this with specific algorithm.
For example, this one is detecting the
iceberg orders, the liquidity that you
cannot see. Let's go on, and let's see
the example that they used to
distribute, and this is an example that
I always like to make to explain the
activity of the institutional player.
They have necessity to fill large amount
of orders. So, as you can see, they put
multiple iceberg orders on the way up.
So, they put the first one here, as you
can see, the second one here, and the
third one is the one that really stopped
the market and got filled completely,
and the market start to collapse, and
they reloaded, okay? Even before the
liquidity. So, everyone that is scalping
here will think, "Okay, I will enter if
I see an absorption here." But the
market never reached this level, and you
can stay there waiting that the market
goes there. But the real reason is
because the iceberg got filled
completely on this level, on the 27,875,
around this level, okay? So, it never
managed to reach liquidity. And also
here, as you can see on the bottom,
there was a major liquidity level here
that a lot of players could wait for the
market to reach that never got reached
because the price wanted to go long and
got filled the orders even before. How
they can do this? Using algorithm that
fill order fractionalized, okay? In a
fractionalized way. So, instead of
putting the full order, okay, on the
limit that you will see like this, they
just reload the level, okay? So, you
fill the reload, they fill the reload.
You fill the reload and there is a way
to spot it using specific iceberg
detection method. Hope you enjoyed it.
Leave a like and a comment if you like
this kind of content. So, we are now in
live market environment on the 4th of
May, 2026 and I would like to show you
how much this can get useful when you
need to get a feeling level. As you can
see, here they fill multiple levels, one
here, one here, one here. All these
resting liquidity, but the only level
that managed to have a push up and to
create a real movement is the one that
got supported, as you can see in this
area, by the reload level, okay? This is
really important. Here you can see a
clear absorption on this resting
liquidity and this can be a level that
still they struggle to break and that if
they manage to take control could give
to the price a squeeze on the way up
where you see a lot of aggressive orders
eating the book because you have a major
filling level on the 27,900
and 40, 939, 940, okay? So, this one
seems to me as an accumulation phase.
Let's see how this one behave, but as
you can see here you have multiple
levels really low and then you have a
thick level of resting liquidity here
that could be revisit and you have here
exactly the pattern of reload. So, when
you have an absorption of the sellers
and aggression of the buyers and they
put a resting liquidity, but in this
case fresh to protect and fuel the
movement up. As you can see here, they
are trying to protect the horizontal
level getting filled more sell order,
but as you can see from here the buyers
are trying to get aggressively and
squeeze. Let me go deeper so you can see
the interaction in real time and this
one is live market guys and you can see
that these buyers got absorbed exactly
at this horizontal liquidity level and
the next level that they are going to
target is this intermediate level that
got created now on the 27,890.
You can see that the aggressive sell
orders are taking control and this
27,875.
These are the two main level that we
could reach. And as you can see here the
sellers got really aggressive on the way
down. They absorb the buyers, they put
their load here and now the battle it's
it's getting more hard and the
volatility it's also going higher
because this market it's analyzing the
regime of volatility and it's giving you
the probability of getting in any
direction. As you can see here, they are
battling on this horizontal level on the
27,890
and it seems from how the orders are
unfolding that the sellers are losing
the control of the situation and buyers
want to really to push to get aggressive
and to finally break this level to go on
the main level of liquidity that is the
27,940.
Look how much liquidity there is here.
This will make the grill, the pattern of
Enrico Stucky. In the meantime, while I
comment the session, I will show you the
settings and a small tutorial of the
Deep Tone platform. We can see that here
we have all the drawing tools. If you
are a price action trader, you need to
mark the most important level of the
battle. So you need to mark where the
sellers took control and when the last
time the buyers took control and the
intermediate level of liquidity. And
also let me explain something here. I've
been a price action trader for years and
I was always assuming liquidity.
Watching liquidity in real time how it
interact with orders. The real liquidity
is letting you really understand how the
auction move. And this is important
because as a price action trader you can
be extremely profitable using pattern,
but you are always in the in this kind
of mindset where you need to draw
important levels of liquidity and assume
where it can be. But in this case we saw
this one in real time. We understood the
auction in real time. And we are
understanding also this one how they
reloaded the level and where they are
going next here on the 27,875
and why they are going there. Then other
than this we can customize everything.
We can customize the contrast. So if you
want to have more visible level, I
prefer them to be darker, okay? Because
so so I can see only the most important
level here and the other one fade also
the market maker activity is less
visible on the chart. You can manage to
select the bubble grouping as you
prefer. For example, if you want to
trade absorption and reversal, you can
put this in the 70 to 75% to spot in a
really simple way where buyers or seller
get absorbed. Look at this huge
horizontal absorption that you have here
and aggression of the buyers. And you
can also select here the size of the
bubbles. So you can decide if you want
to have more or if you want to have
intermediate. That is I think it's more
pleasant for the eye, specifically if
you scalp for multiple hours per day.
And then the contrast of liquidity. So
if you don't want bright color, you can
go in the 80% and only see really the
most important level. And as you see
here, they are trying to squeeze this
top and complete the grill pattern. So
filling all this liquidity horizontal
level and squeezing the top,
accelerating with this big bubble, doing
what I call the squeeze. So eating all
these level horizontal level of
liquidity, filling all these level on
the 27,912
and doing a big aggressive move to go to
the next station. This is what I call
the next station, okay? This is the
other horizontal level of liquidity. And
as you can see, on this case, we can see
the interaction of the players. The
buyers try to push, the sellers
protected, but the buyers reloaded,
reloaded the fresh liquidity. And this
is the first information that you can
get that there is interest in
continuation. Even if the sellers will
try to push it through, the fact that
there is passive liquidity here is the
break and protect. So, trying to get And
as you can see, this is an example live
of how the reload unfold, okay? Look at
this beauty. So, they managed to break
this horizontal level, the sellers
reloaded, but also the buyers reload.
And here you can see the sellers
encountering a wall of liquidity on the
reload side. And now, you can see the
buyers eating all the level of
liquidity. If they squeeze this one on
the top and they reach this one,
probably, with high probability, they
will go for a fast move all the way up
because, as you can see, this level is
pretty empty, okay? Yes, you have
something on the 27,000
and 125, but mainly here, who is
controlling the auction is buyers. And
you can see from this aggression, no?
Look at this aggression. This is another
example of one side taking control,
catalyzing one movement, and the sellers
trying to recover the movement on the
way down, getting aggressive, as you can
see. They are trying to push the market
back to the fair value. Which one is the
fair value of all this range? The fair
value of all this range, you can see
here, is the origin of the move. So, it
sold this aggression, and the buyers put
what? Uh, fresh liquidity. This is a
reload. I don't know if this will get
filled. You don't have a guarantee that
the fresh liquidity gets filled, but
this is an information. They break, and
immediately after they break, they
reload liquidity. So, they want to get
more contracts filled to go long. This
is important because this one here it's
protecting the intention to go higher.
And in this case, if you see this one
doesn't always happen, but if you see
this one raising, perfect. If you see
this one raising, means that they are
willing to get filled at higher level to
be in the movement. And this is an
amazing confirmation of the buyers
wanting to continue the auction up and
having a breakout movement. And in this
case, we can clearly lead the path of
least resistance on the buy side. So, we
can see that the highest probability is
that we squeeze this high, we go on the
top on the 27,915,
and we fill this level of liquidity. And
here we see the interaction, and you can
do this every single time. Now, when
they break this level, if they break
this level, you see And if you see other
fresh liquidity getting added here, it
means that they want to fuel the
movement up. As of now, the fresh
liquidity is still here, okay? As you
can see, they are adding short, but look
at this movement how much is getting
aggressive. Look how much is fueled by
orders. This is the real auction market
theory. This is the market mechanics at
its finest, okay? They strike one of the
most important liquidity level, and as
you can see, the buyers give back the
rain. So, they get They got really
aggressive here, but they found a
ceiling. And this is important for take
profit, for partial, can give you a lot
of information of where you can take a
decision of unloading a position. This
is a good piece of information for
scalpers, for example. As you can see,
the buyers are not willing to get filled
at higher levels, and this is an
information because the sellers could
try here to reload on the way down and
get back to fair value and balance. Why?
Because [snorts] the resting liquidity
and the fresh liquidity is not
protecting the move up, so there is not
a lot of interest. So, the it's solely
in the hands of the aggressive market
participants, the buyers, okay? So, from
the heat map, we can see that one of the
most important level is the 27,925,
this horizontal level. If this one gets
broken, I would like to see exactly the
same that we saw here, breaking and
loading liquidity. This means that is a
sustained move. Look at this aggression,
okay? Let's see if now they add
something on the liquidity side. They
are breaking. They are not having an
easy time break this level, but they are
trying their best to break. See how this
goes. So, the buyers are taking control
and are absorbing sellers on the way
down. So, they are definitely breaking
here, but I don't see resting liquidity
getting hot on the on this level. So, it
means that they are not willing to get
filled here, but they still have this
massive liquidity level on the 27,895.
So, there is a probability that we will
see a retracement of the market. Okay,
if they don't put anything anything
else. We are really close to the final
target level. Let's see how this one
goes. They are rebalancing. They are
rebalancing here. Let me make more
precise the level. This is the level.
One, two. Remember, it's not a level.
It's always an area. It's important to
understand this. When you approach this,
okay, you can see a reversal something
below, okay, because it's not a single
level. You cannot put only in the 72.
You can you needs to understand that
there are orders around it, okay? It's
always an area. Buyers still in control.
Look how much they are getting
aggressive. As you can see, we can
cancel everything here to make the heat
map as clean as possible. Look at this
beauty. We can see how the CVD it's
behaving here. Let me activate on the
bottom of the chart. So, the buyers are
in complete control. You can see here.
Buyers are dominating this auction from
the beginning of the session. We can go
on the view up that is giving you also
the standard deviation of where we are.
And if we zoom out, we can see that we
are above the first standard deviation
of the view up. So, buyers are
definitely in control. This is the fair
value of the day, and this is a level
that we could see filled once they reach
the main heat map level on the 27,940.
Let me also put for you the horizontal
volume, and this one can be really
useful if you want to do some volume
spread analysis, for example, watching
the vertical levels and the absorption
on the vertical levels because this mark
really important levels here, okay? For
example, this aggression here that got
completely stopped is relevant. And also
what you are seeing at the moment, so a
lot of seller aggression is trying to
flip the auction. As you can see, they
put, while I was talking, other fresh
liquidity to fuel the movement. I don't
know if you can see. This is the new
fresh liquidity that they add to fuel
the move- the movement, and the seller
stuck here, as you can see, and they are
flushing all the orders, okay? This one
it's live. It's on
Monday. We just received a missile alert
in the United Arab Emirates, and this is
how the New York session is unfoldings
in terms of orders on the heat map. I
hope you enjoy this kind of content.
This is more technicals. The heat map
it's a little bit more technical and
complicated that what we are usually
watching here, but I think this kind of
master class can give a lot of value to
scalpers that want to improve their
precision. Look at the sellers trying to
take control here. And here they find a
wall. You see the first reaction they
see on the wall is this one, absorption.
And now you can see the second time they
touch. So, when the buyers get filled
here, you can see all these orders,
okay, on the bubbles, and you can see,
look at this beauty, how the market have
an immediate reaction when they reach.
Then they could try to reload, because
here we have a level, but it's important
to understand how much of a strong
reaction we can see at these horizontal
level that are levels that mark the most
important crossing point and check point
of the market participants of the day.
Look at this beauty. Look at this
beauty. This was the most important
level that we had from the beginning of
the session. I hope you enjoy content.
Let me know if you like the breakdown
live of how you can use them the heat
map, and how you can build a the
liquidity heat map confluence on the
order flow analysis. Of course, today
the bias was was on the long side, and
how you can get also a better feeling
level using nothing else that market
microstructure. This is not science of
orders, okay? Some conspiracy theory.
This is how the market moves. These data
are provided directly from the exchange,
so you have one certainty. You know for
a fact that these data are real and
these data are actual levels waiting to
get filled paired with actual execution
on the bubble. I hope you enjoy this
kind of content. Let me know in the
comment section and leave a like if you
enjoy this kind of breakdown of the
session. Okay, this is the original
level that we were watching before, the
one that we mark after the opening of
the session. And as you can see, this is
what I want you to watch in the heat map
because it's a really objective piece of
information. They had an absorption of
the buyers here. We had the buyers
getting really aggressive on the top
getting absorbed and this is a perfect
example of a reload. So the sellers say,
"Look, you don't go anywhere." And from
here they took control and the the
sellers are getting aggressive, okay?
And they eat this original level of
liquidity here, as you can see. And the
second level of liquidity that you have
is this one, this 27,915.
So you can see that they didn't remove
this liquidity, so they still have a
bias on the long side, but now they are
having a really difficult time breaching
through this level. Now they are
approaching again, let's see how they
behave and they are raising this
liquidity, you see? Before was here,
then it was here, then it it's here. So
if they manage to break, this one is the
next sensitive level with a high
probability of getting filled, okay? And
here we can see also how the sellers are
behaving. The sellers, when the buyers
started retracing and started to get
aggressive, the sellers place another
level of passive liquidity. So they want
more order to get filled. Now let's see
if a big absorption buy is placed here.
Here you can see, but this one could be
a level that bring the sellers in a
potential retracement phase, okay? So
from here we could expect that the
buyers get a really convinced of
breaking through, so we need to see a
lot of buyers aggression bubble. But in
this case, what we can see with the
highest probability is that the sellers
wants to get more order filled, wants to
complete the distribution to go back to
the main level, so the 27,915.
This is the reading and market reading
that I would make considering that I
have a long bias for the day. You always
needs to consider that even if your bias
it's on the long side, you still have
retracement on the main direction of the
day, okay? And this one and this one on
the top specifically could be levels
that bring
>> [laughter]
>> that bring an amazing retracement for
the day. This is a incredible aggression
that we have. They are filling all the
levels. They filled the first, they
filled the second. They missed only this
one and then if they break this one,
they have one really low on the 27,850,
but I think this is enough to start on
the way back and you can see here that
they are getting aggressive. Now, let's
see what the CVD is telling us and the
CVD as you can see is flipping lower.
So, even if the main direction of the
day is higher, they are getting
aggressive on the downside. What does it
mean? That I will not try reversal play.
I will not try to get long while the
sellers are dominating the auction
because it's a suicide, okay? I will
wait for the buyers to show me some kind
of protection. They filled all the
levels, you see? These were levels that
we had from before and when they accept
above this level, look at this
liquidity. This is fresh liquidity,
okay? This is a potential reload. So,
this liquidity level here is telling us,
"Look that from this level there is a
high probability that you have a
rebound, okay?" So, you have an
absorption of the sellers here and you
go back to the main liquidity area of
the sellers. And then we see from here
if the aggressive buyers have the power
and the strength to go higher. Look how
much they are aggressive the sellers
here, still going aggressively down and
if they manage to break this horizontal
level that still is getting protected in
the blue area, you have a flip of the
auction and you flip the bias of the
day. So, it means that your next target
is the 27,870
or the 27,850.
As of now, buyers are still protecting
and the real battle is here on the
27,910.
This is where you can see if the buyers
is are having enough strength to get
aggressive on the level. See what they
do. Let's see also the CBD. CBD is
stable, so there is no aggression of the
buyers, but the market is going up. So
this means that if we have a flip here
and we see a buy aggression of the
buyers, we could make a lot of points on
the up. Compressed, compressed, no
aggression of the buyers, no aggression
of the buyers. They are starting to have
a little bit of movement here. Look at
the sellers always protecting on this
horizontal level. Once they reach the
27,900, the sellers show their hand
really aggressively. This one seems to
me like an accumulation area and the
reason is this horizontal level it's
showing a lot of absorption here. They
filled completely the 27,900
and they are going back as you can see
to this passive liquidity level. Look at
Look at the order that got aggressive on
this level and they broke the level. So
they flipped the auction reload of the
sellers. Look at this reload. Reload of
the sellers number one, reload of the
sellers number two. What does it mean?
That they wants to get more order filled
and this could be for the reason that
they wants to get this horizontal level
filled. So they could Now they got
filled completely. This one could be an
information that we have that the
auction Look at this amazing reaction
here. The auction would go to the
27,870.
So if I took a short from here, I would
consider bringing my full take profit
way lower than the low. So for example
here, filled now, okay? Okay, now let's
go on why this kind of information are
important. So first of all, with the
liquid heat map, you can predict with a
high degree of accuracy which kind of
volatility you could expect and today
was telling us that we were high
volatility. But more than this, on all
the breakdown in the live session that I
gave you before, in the end, the level
that I marked for you, the most
important liquidity level was the top.
And this kind of information you cannot
see only with execute order because you
don't know where there is the massive
liquidity wall of the passive orders.
Second of all, with my confirmation I
would have taken the first trade here,
okay? This timing difference can be a
lot of filling execution divergence,
okay? So, you you can be filled way
lower if you don't know when to search
for setups. And also, when you have the
confirmation, for example, on the Nasdaq
effort, watching what happened from the
liquidity heat map, exactly the level
that they rejected here, seeing
horizontally the 27,910
and 912, and knowing that this pattern
here on this absorption of the buyers
and this reload here, it's exactly where
the Nasdaq effort printed, is giving me
the confidence to go to the next level
of liquidity. Where is the most
important next level of liquidity after
the touch? This one got consumed, this
one got consumed, which level do we have
here below? We have here below this
level of liquidity. Okay, we have the
27,790 that is super far, and we have
this cluster. So, we have TP1 and TP2
here, okay? And today, the Nasdaq
unfolded collapsing like this. Now, this
was
also a news about Iran, and here in UAE,
the attacks are getting back, but the
situation that we can see here, also
this is the second Nasdaq effort area.
What can you notice? You can notice that
you have liquidity heat map level here,
okay? Removed. Putting lowered. What
does it mean that they want to get
filled and they are willing to get
filled at lower levels? You see this
amazing absorption, on top of this you
see reload, reload, reload, reload. This
is all fresh liquidity fueling the
movement down, and you can see that here
you have Nasdaq effort and Nasdaq effort
area. So, this is another example of how
you can pair all this information that
you have from the heat map. Look how
much the price is rejecting this level
here from an aggressive from aggressive
participants. Pairing this information,
for example, the bounce that we had when
we reached the maximum point of
liquidity resting here, and these are
levels that they put after, so this is
fresh liquidity and this is fresh
liquidity, and this is fresh liquidity,
okay? So, this is another example of
reload. Look at this. This is an
absorption and reload here. It's giving
you a lot of confidence about when to
engage in setups, okay? And it's giving
you a better timing advantage over other
players here. I hope you enjoy this kind
of video and see you in the next one.